yippee K we'll be lovers I'm John and in
this video I'm explaining the shocking
ending of the Invisible Man and the
thrilling twists and clues that led to
that big moment plus I'll reveal how the
finale connects to the new Invisible
Woman film spoilers of course for the
movie so take care of you haven't seen
it yet the film's first jaw-dropping
surprise happens when Cecilia's at
dinner with her sister Emily and out of
nowhere the Invisible Man
slashes Emily's throat and pins the
murder on C by placing the knife in her
hand leading up to this adrian has been
slowly making Cecilia look and feel
crazy first faking his own death
then stalking and terrorizing her at her
friend's house one of the first big
clues foreshadowing Emily's murder comes
when Cecilia's alone in the house with
Invisible Man and she decides to call
Adrian's cell phone which buzzes from
the Attic above sea climbs up there and
after finding the phone together with a
large kitchen knife a text message pops
up with a single word surprise she can't
figure out why there's a knife there but
the sign that it's a future murder
weapon is how it's already bagged like
it's a piece of evidence when she's
later locked up and drugged in a mental
hospital for the crime and what everyone
thinks her her delusional ravings and
invisible Adrian whispers try tormenting
her that he had this moment planned all
along the word an idea of surprise pays
off in an even bigger way in the movies
final twist when C goes to have dinner
with Adrian he still thinks he's in
control and tells her I know you better
than anyone else in the world that
shouldn't come as a surprise the way
Adrian pauses smiles and then emphasizes
the words surprise is his way of letting
her know that it was indeed him who
killed her sister and who's been
torturing her not just his brother his
constant denials at the dinner table
prior to this yet another example of how
he gasps likes her and so sick of his
continued abuse Cecilia excuses herself
to the bathroom then off camera sneaks
into the bedroom closet where she
recovers the invisible suit she hid
there earlier
invisible now she walks back to the
dinner table and aware of the security
cameras makes him slit his own throat
mirroring the way he killed her sister
as he dies she whispers the word
surprise showing that she's turned his
own tricks back on him by the way notice
how Cecilia decided they eat steak
rather than the sushi or pasta she was
also offered for dinner so that Adrian
would be holding the knife she needed to
kill him and a clue that si would decide
to wear the invisibility suit against
Adrian was hinted at in the hospital on
a poster titled you don't have to face
yourself alone the poster features two
silhouetted figures facing away from
each other and while it's obviously
aimed at people with mental health
issues may be bipolar for example it
also plays on the idea of si using an
alternate invisible persona to deal with
Adrian as well as the fact that we soon
discover that a second man donned the
invisible suit
indeed doubles and mirrors are occurring
theme in the movie with Cecilia seeing a
reflection of herself in the bathroom
mirror just before she puts the
invisible suit on to kill Adrian part of
the setup for Cecilia hiding the second
invisibility suit in the bedroom closet
comes in the scene where she goes for a
job interview and the interviewer says
we both know the value of closet space
which points forward to the film's
finale as well as back to the start of
the movie were si hid a go-bag in a
closet to help her escape Adrian as we
discover in another twist Adrian's
brother Tom was also his accomplice
helping him faked his own death and even
once wearing the suit Tom claimed he'd
been controlled by Adrian all his life
and while that may be true
he still lied to Cecilia feeding her
false information essentially
gaslighting her as well only thing more
brilliant than inventing something that
makes you invisible is not inventing it
but making it think he did when si tells
Thom he's just a jellyfish version of
his brother she means he lacks a spine
but the fact that jellyfish are known
for their translucent or transparent
look means it's also an intriguing nod
to the fact that Tom will later were the
invisible suit Tom was always quite
shady from the start knowing things he
shouldn't such as were si was living
remember she received the letter about
Adrian's will at James's house probably
because when Emily saw the news about
his death she ignored Seeds instructions
not to go there and Adrian was tracking
or watching her just as he predicted Tom
also knew that cioud set of a bank
account for Sydney's college fund again
something that should be private most
likely is that while Adrian was stalking
Cecilia as well as breaking into our
laptop he was keeping tabs on her and
relaying the info back to his brother as
the saying goes the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the
world he didn't exist an idea that
perfectly fits the character of the
Invisible Man even at the end of the
movie Adrian pretends he was never the
Invisible Man and that it was his
brother Tom he was responsible for
everything that happened
Adrian flips the truth so far that he
even claims he's the victim and that tom
was controlling him the movies writer
director Leigh Whannell has said that
Adrian's emotional intelligence and
charm is a classic trait of narcissists
and sociopaths who he describes as
scientists of the human condition who
can break someone down very quickly
assess their needs and desires and play
to that which is why Adrian is good at
reading people for example when they
were still together he figured out
without her even saying a word that she
wanted to leave him and his reaction was
that of a sociopath oh you girl I was
standing my bone there I know you better
than anyone else in the world
when Cecilia was wearing a wire at the
end and trying to get him to confess you
could sense he probably knew what she
was doing and on top of wanting to
Gaslight her as usual that was another
reason he refused to admit anything
openly likewise his earlier comment that
you're the only person in the world who
gets to see my hand shake was a tactic
to let her know that only she knows the
truth about him and no one else would
believe her he also knew she was taking
birth control pills in secret so
switched them out behind her back
essentially drugging her so she'd get
pregnant quite likely with dye szczepan
given the very high level of it in her
blood the Cecilia unwittingly continues
to take the drugs
Adrian breaks into her email sending a
threatening incriminating message from
her to her sister which later provides
the motive for Emily's murder Adrian is
constantly isolating see from the few
people already in her life as well as
any new people she comes into contact
with
he also sabotages her job interview that
could make her financially independent
of his money by emptying her portfolio
briefcase
he later puts those architect plans that
he took in the Attic together with the
kitchen knife taunting her about what he
can do to her
he also sees himself as an amazing
godlike figure the master of everyone
and everything around him when they were
a couple he was such a control freak
that he decided everything Cecilia did
war and even said even his dog Zeus was
a shock collar with tech of Adrian's own
design and let's talk about the name he
chose for that dog the ancient Greek
deity Zeus is the king of all the other
gods and men which again highlights how
adrian imagines himself as a supreme
master and God of all and it's no
coincidence that the location of
Adrian's house is celestial drive as a
genius inventor Adrian uses his
invisibility technology to
psychologically and physically terrorize
the Celia and those around her to make
her appear unhinged and ultimately drive
her back to him when she asks the
Invisible Man why he cares about her
when with all his wealth and power he
could have almost anyone the answer that
Tom later gives her is that Adrian needs
her because she doesn't need him and
that nobody's ever left him before when
Alice said that when he was writing his
first draft of the movie he felt that
the themes of gaslighting
domestic abuse are not being believed or
feeling like there's an unseen threat
would perfectly fit a modern version of
the classic Invisible Man villain and
Whannell went on to say that the horror
genre lends itself to depicting the
worst of society's problems because it
can illustrate our collective fears
Cecilia's character as an example of
what it's like for a woman to be driven
to feel crazy in the wake of abuse when
no one around you believes what you're
saying ultimately a see couldn't make
Adrian admit his guilt the legal options
for getting justice weren't available so
he would have continued to terrorize her
as the Invisible Man if she didn't stay
with him which is why when L says that
with the ending he decided to give
Cecilia some catharsis as he wanted her
to feel free and so a sea walks out of
Adrian's house free at last we can see
from her open bag that she still got her
invisibility suit meaning she could
easily be in a sequel or possibly in
universals Invisible Woman movie which
is already in development with Elizabeth
Banks directing as starring as a title
character I wonder if the film will
feature banks donning the suit and using
it
to violently deal with people who've
evaded justice such as abusers after all
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
tone of the new film is Thelma and
Louise meets American Psycho well though
Universal have abandoned their dark
universe which was going to connect
their catalogue of classic monsters it
seems there is potential for some sort
of crossover even a very small one if
the studio did decide it wants to make
it happen if they did want to connect
the two movies then Cecilia could for
example supply Banks's Invisible Woman
with the tech for the invisible suit or
they could even team up either way if
Cecilia shows in The Invisible Man
stalking is a very real danger in real
life and online as well as covering up
your webcam like Cecilia did to stop
potential hackers spying on her you can
also stop anyone including your own
Internet service provider from tracking
you online with a Virtual Private
Network VPN helps protect your privacy
by encrypting your internet connection
and preventing your ISP government
agencies or malicious hackers from
reading your emails private messages or
knowing which websites you're visiting
which is a perfect intro for this video
sponsor Nord VPN who offer one of the
world's best virtual private networks
here at flicks in the city we've tested
several VPNs and Nord is one of the best
and fastest it has over five thousand
servers to choose from in over 60
countries and when connected to Nord we
were still able to get blisteringly fast
download speeds
unlike many free VPNs Nord has a no log
policy meaning it doesn't record or
retain details of your online activity
when you're connected to its service and
if you're a video junkie Nord VPN can
help you bypass fewer restrictions or
censorship on content not available to
view in your country just pick a server
in another location and browse the
Internet as if you were there Nord VPN
even works with Netflix plus you can
connect up to six devices at the same
time including your laptop and phone so
you can keep your mobile devices safe
whenever you're travelling and using
public Wi-Fi for a limited time Nord VPN
are offering all our viewers up to 70%
off new subscriptions and a bonus
subscription absolutely free just visit
Nord VPN comm slash flicks or tap the
link in the video description to access
the offer that's Nord VPN
slash flicks for a huge 70% discount and
an additional subscription period for
free so what do you think of the
Invisible Man the twist and the ending
leave your thoughts in the comments
below if you enjoyed this than a thumbs
up and share hugely appreciated tapleft
to watch my next horror movie video or
tap write for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time you PK movie lovers